s
du FBI à la résidence
de Donald Trump à Mar-a-Lago
le matin du 8 août?
Et pourqEt qui a donné le feu v?
"Le président Biden n'était pas
au courant", dit la porte-parole
de la Maison-Blanche.
Mais les questions fusent de
partout.
Pour ses partisans, il n'y
a aucun doute, c'est de la
persécution politique contre
l'ex-président.
"Ils ne devraient pas faire ça,
"C'est inapproprié",
i-ci.
"Ils ont peur qu'il soit
candidat à la présidence",
Ce que l'on sait, c'est qu'enjs
nationales avaient récupéré
15 boîtes de dossier à ld Trump
en Floride. L'ancien président
les aurait rapportées de la
Maison-Blanche. Or, la loi
est très claire asident doit ree
l'ensemble de ses échanges,
courriels, lettres, documents,
aux Archives nationales.
Même son ancienne attachéettttt
très négligeant, qu'il jettait
des documents.
Et il y a deux mois, quatre
enquêteurs, dont le chef du
contre-espionnage du ministère
de la Justice, se seraientrendur
les avocats de Donald Trump
pour voir où se trouvaient
des dossiers. Ils auraient même
réclamé qu'ils soient placés
dans une pièce sécurisée.
Selon les experts, tout doit
être conservé aux Archives
nationales, car cela relève
de la sécurité nationale et
le FBI ne lésine pas avec ces
questions-là.
"C'est une journée étrange",
dit Donald Trump, comparant sa
situation à celle du Watergate.
Et tous les ténors républicains,
dont le gouverneur
la Floride, se portent
à sa défense. Tous parlent
d'instrumentalisation de la
justice à des fins politiques.
"C'est e", écrie", écrie", écre
leader républicain à la chambre,
Kevin McCarthy, affirmant qu'il
y aura enquête contre le
ministre de la Justice, Merrick
Garland,publicains
remportent le congrès aux
élections de mi-mandat.
"Nous sommes à 90 jours des
élections de mi-mandat, dit-il.
Le FBI fait une perquisition
chez le futur candidat pour
2024. Je veux savoir pourquoi."
"Personne n'est au-dessus de la
loi", rappelait Merrick Garland
il y a un mois. Il vient d'en
faire la preuve.
Donald Trump pourrait se
déclarer candidat ines
élections présidentielles à tout
moment et il espère que cette
perquisition va galvaniser ses
troupes.
Ici Azeorghis,orghis,orghis,or,